okay it is 8:13
p.m. why are we live at 88:13
p.m. frankly I have no idea but
um I guess we are and we may as well do
some
work just a little
bit I just really want to figure out
this one thing with the r turns on this
it drives me nuts and I don't understand
what the hell is wrong
hey
bet good
point don't do
that slightly
better Ah that's too
bright hey
I'm trying to think how this would
work you're fitting this to the variance
of the return
oh
yeah you get a value function out of
this the predictions are pretty darn
but the value function is normally
trying to predict this isn't
it with squared
error it
is does this get better if we run it for
longer
yeah extricated the advantage well it's
different it's um
in this case the discounting itself is
learned or it's supposed to
have hang on how does this make any
sense reward
though hang on maybe this just doesn't
get
it there's no learnable gamma on this
either at the
moment oh wait no there is
doesn't go backwards
though
so does that make
so you
predict you get a value for each uh you
get a value predict for each mean and
standard deviation we aren't learning
value
function at all we are learning value
function we in fact we're learning a
very large and variational value
function you predict mean
value for the next Horizon
steps as well as standard
deviation but the question is what to
fit those
two
so if the value is supposed to represent
the discounted
return how does this work in the normal
po
setting you end up with
discounted
rewards the value function bootstrap at
the
end
right
yeah you
do
and the value
function is trained to
maximize discounted
reward is that different from what I've
just
there
Advantage where's the value function
St discounted
reward okay
yes maybe there's no contradiction here
this is correct
yeah oh hang
on no this is fine
I'm just trying to figure out if there's
something circular here where you
destabilize it because the thing is
you're
including you're using the value
function to compute the advantage and
you're using the uh the terms of the
advantage to train the value
function so it seems a bit circular but
maybe it's not and I'm looking at my
case
here and I'm thinking that maybe my case
isn't really circular either
but I need to think a little bit about
the discount Factor
still
so gamma in the original it is not in
mine
these These are where is
it I don't know if you can see on camera
0.5%
alcohol and it just tastes like a good
normal
beer so I get to have beer again without
having to have the
alcohol it just send me un limited of
this
stuff not
really they've got 65 calories a
piece and I'm getting kind of fat but
that's just going to happen until I get
back to my uh original weight
and I'm able to start cutting
what line you learning in gamma
here
um well technically that would be
here so Gan negative log
likelihood
on the mean
value computer
return and then the variance predicted
for that
value five minutes I've been deving this
on stream for a while
here
um but I'm trying to figure out
right it's so so hard to think about
this cuz it's like it's a telescoping
sum and then you have to understand the
interpretation of that sum and how it
behaves if you optimize
it now [ __ ] that I'm going to do the
problem when I want to do the problem
useful I mean I know how I would apply
the discounting
factor if I wanted to
do to have a
telescope actually I think it does have
to
yeah I think it does have to right
because the thing
is if I'm trying to make this be
like it's hard to say
honestly I could just do it that way
actually hang on let me think about this
maybe there is a principled way of
approaching this hold
on that contribute as
oh wait so that's very weird actually
um so if you predict
I really don't know if you have to apply
this exponential or not
think maybe I'm
wrong it's very difficult to develop an
intuition around this thing it's even
more difficult to explain it on the
stream does this thing train as it is
now
really am not sure that this is correct
though
return
Branch what do you
no it
doesn't I have versions that
do andan I guess the closest version of
this would
this they're just some intermediate
things I was looking at
this still going to
explode
yeah
um okay so that shouldn't happen
right goes to zero
right TR I think what a good way to test
this would
yeah it's not
good mean there's just too much in here
that's not good
thing I think if I'm going to do
bootstrapping I think it has to be done
completely differently from this doesn't
bootstrapping then I don't think that
you need this this gamma
right might be easier to
learn I think you need it
though hang on maybe you
uncertainty will
increase over the
horizon which will cause the behavior
that we were seeing okay
let me think about how that should be
handled
let me
see yeah that is a problem
I'm really starting to wonder if I
shouldn't have done this in Cuda but I
think I have to
the uncertainty should come from the or
the discount should come from the
uncertainty of the value function
shouldn't it
should it might need to be scaled though
bro what's the problem yeah I'm not
explaining anything very well at all so
this is a new Advantage function aiming
to replace generalized Advantage
estimation um it works by instead of
predicting a single value trained to
match discounted returns it predicts
values for the next 32 64 or say 128
steps 128 different values it also
predicts standard deviations for those
values so it's variational and the goal
is to use the standard deviations which
give you the uncertainty of those
predictions uh in order to learn a
discounting factor so so in a in essence
this thing is supposed to be able
to learn to do credit assignment over
different
Horizons based on its
certainty um in what rewards it thinks
it's going to
get but it's kind of a little bit of a
mind Bender here with how you set up the
value function training and that's what
I'm trying to deal with at the moment
the code that I have here is a Cuda
kernel for disadvantage
function because it's a little Annoying
the way it works and it's horribly
horribly slow if you don't write a
kernel for
it very fast if you
do whatever it's just breakout but
that's
irrelevant this is not like a this un
for that un it's like a very core
fundamental algorithm
problem I'm gonna get this
though be very very good if I could get
this to
work yeah the thing is like I've already
kind of seen that on breakout you can
get like you can get something to
perform very well um with like even
completely unreasonable things
so it's really about getting the design
of it correct and then testing it in a
lot of ends sounds complicated good luck
not my spere yeah well I mean this is
you know sometimes this stream is watch
me build cool environments live
sometimes the stream is we just deal
with really hard research problems that
are not exactly in my area either
because that's what is needed to push
reinforcement learning forward right and
and like if you ask a like a very good
math guy the stuff I'm going through is
going to look very stupid but who cares
and we're going to solve it eventually
and we're going to have a nice
algorithm so that's the core issue
maybe I will start like diagramming some
of this stuff
out and be more interactive and maybe
I'll solve more stuff that
way that is
blinding okay so the neuron that is
going to Output
t plus
Horizon and then there also going to
Output
Sigma
T Sigma oops not how you write
Sigma t plus +
1 okay so these are what we have now we
need to Define two
functions just two
functions we need to
advantage uh sub t
we'll give it a half because it's
uh an estimate I
believe
okay and then this is going to take in
as
parameters you're allowed to use V
T and we'll give this a
vector you're allowed to use
Sigma
T vector
and you also get the
rewards
T okay so we need this
function the advantage
function and then we also
need
function but the value function is very
similar to this
all we really need for the value
function is the
return and if we just
do
equals well it's in the PO paper let me
find it it's a simple formula for that
yeah so Advantage is just uh I mean
return is just this plus b
okay
Advantage Plus Fe let me let me write
that
in
return t
equal a at
t
plus uh V
T and there's no Vector on this
one so that one is easy so really we
just need this Advantage
function
okay um and I think what we're doing
right
so
gamma of
I
equals so it is one
over Sigma
s
i over
Sigma squar so this is just a
norm so it just
normalize 1 over Sigma
squ okay and then we're
plus I guess we don't really use this VP
here at all
so one one thing you notice is that
this the sum strictly increases the
farther out you
go you know I'm
wondering I'm wondering if we do keep
the
exponential on
here I don't even know if that fixes
it well hang on
because we also need to
what do we do about the importance
waiting of these terms
why isn't this a problem
normally a problem normally because you
have fixed gamas right they're applied
exponentially and they're not
trained okay so the problem here is that
this is
trained oh okay I think I see the
solution to
this
linearly here into of the sum is sum of
okay so you divide by
well I guess you would
but that's going to mess it up isn't
it no that's going to mess it up
you might not have Cuda Dev tools or the
dev version of Cuda I mean
what I have some
ideas I have some ideas
again reward block gives you gamma
right okay
no this doesn't make sense either does
it not
yeah still doesn't quite make sense does
it
rewards the value is trained to predict
that hang on I might have something
this brings us back to mean reward
doesn't it
have it
training
hard I could
predict
I don't think this helped me this gives
me gives me a clean reward signal to
train on
yeah I don't know what advantage you do
then you're already
predicting yeah it seems weird to
produce a Value Estimate like this at
every step doesn't
it it seems very weird to produce a
Value Estimate like this step by step
though maybe I do have this I had this
correct
earlier
so if I just
do if I predict per time step
right it's hard to learn
that it's not really that much hard to
learn though than the other one okay so
let me say I produce per time step value
estimates and then the
advantage is going to be the
sum as
before maybe that does
maybe that was
it maybe I had it right the whole time I
just second
guessed is
it okay we're going to do this for a
little bit and then I'm going to sleep
make a commit though
gamma then what do you train this
again
hang
on I have something I think is right
now might need tweaks but I think the
concept is now right
it's fine
though so
one oh it means the last gamma is
is too
high
yeah okay so why do that
happen why do it
happen
here ah hold on it's because you have to
go forward a step isn't it
I mean this is not an unreasonable
Horizon but the issue is going to
be this will Plateau
flat is the issue
on maybe there is something I can
do Horizon is 32 by default it
though maybe it should be
some or minus value Meo for
that that would be thinking right
do then I have to scale it so that
gamma oh no this works right
what's wrong with
you somebody
does this make
sense you're now training against the
true
over I'll tells you how to wait each
each one of these doesn't it
passable while lots of things work the
question is
whether it's
breakout uh I would really like to not
have to zero these Buffs
ERS let me just make sure it still
trains if I do
that I think you do have to zero The
Mask
block make sure it's
consistent yeah but we're going to see
if it does it
faster or about as fast at
least I'd settle for at the same speed
if it's if it does it at the same so if
this algorithm works at the same speed
for a variety of M's it's a
come on it's
[Music]
different yeah it's
different okay well let's make sure this
one
works
again make sure this Repros and then
we'll run it as a
that's good progress at
least do we have people yelling at me
that's
funny
[Music]
cope I swear if you just post anything
negative about AI at
all and like not even like pessimistic
about tech but just like hey guys you
should probably still learn to code
instead of just like you know brain
damage replacing your intelligence with
grock or GPT it's like no I don't want
to think anymore I want the AI to think
for me it's like actually ridiculous
I mean it's kind of just crazy to me
right like imagine being a lazy [ __ ] who
just sits on your ass all day who
doesn't bother to learn anything and
then gets mad at the on the internet
when people say Hey you know you should
probably learn something instead of
hoping that AI will just Outsource all
forms of
intelligence
like especially the the like the
programming hate people it's like no
okay imagine that people have dedicated
years or Decades of their life to
getting good at actually understanding
how these systems work and building the
AI and now you're like ha loser imagine
being a programmer imagine building this
AI when I can just use the AI that you
built it's
crazy I don't get
it I don't get it but
and if you're bad you really can't 10x
is the thing with AI the way it is now
it's too
stupid ironically you can only 10x what
you're producing now if you're bad right
if you're really bad it'll give you
something like kind of passively
acceptable but not
really does it actually
that's
hilarious and actually the reason that I
went down that whole rical with the
other version of that function in the
first place is from a stupid grock
suggestion which I mean it took me a
really long time to figure out why the
suggest was stupid to be fair but it was
stupid in the
end and mind you that's not in an area
where I'm exactly you know up on my game
of what
is like I don't spend ball day doing
math most of the time I really don't
launched I think it's also I think I
think it's fair that
we we comment out gamma and Lambda right
we don't need to sweep them if we're not
using
them so that is part of the
uh
Advantage no it's not edgy it's
literally it's just one less variable
going into the galin process or two few
variables
I'm not committing this I'm just doing
it for the experiment
there actually really only
are
oops so there really only are four
really key hyper parameters right it's
in a rough order it's um learning rate
gamma Lambda and entropy
soon
cool e
and then we'll try some stuff after um I
mean this is like this is a good
progress
yeah there 1.1 1.2 million
train very nice we'll see how that goes
you know no big expectations for it but
it's cool I also I found this old gift
this one's fun right Big nurl Mo map we
should do more with this
end okay um
I think that'll be it I think I'm going
to go get some rest send an email or two
maybe but I need to mainly just get some
rest Twitter's been going well I gotta
post more Pokemon
hilarious all right uh I'm going to get
get some rest so couple of folks
watching all my stuff's at puff. it's
all open source you want to help us out
for free St the GitHub join the Discord
and follow on X for more content the
blog here including a nice RL quick
start guide for beginners and there's
stuff for Cutting Edge as well so uh
thank you and I will probably be back